[Musique]
vous accompagnons le territoire depuis
huit ans sur différentes thématiques la
mobilité la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments la transition écologique la
méthanisation ou les énergies
renouvelables ou le plus récemment
l'autoconsommation de l'énergie qui soit
auto produites par les par différents
types d'acteurs
il s'agira de mini débat
avec qui seront modérées par différents
acteurs et duclos climat énergie leur
permettant chacun de s'exprimer sur
leurs positions qu'elle soit du niveau
du territoire où qu'elle soit du niveau
des acteurs ou expert de la société
civile
[Musique]
nous avons créé les jeux recevoir
monsieur le rat merckaert monsieur jean
baptiste à monique eva roussel et
bertrand coq a requis par ailleurs et le
président du club climat énergie chacun
pourra débattre avec un acteur de la
société civile pour échanger sur les
thématiques comme le numérique
l'aménagement du territoire les
mobilités et les circuits courts
c'est de mettre des projets de manière
collaborative c'est d'ailleurs
finalement plutôt de déposer une
réflexion unique sur la manière de
concevoir une solution nous la faisons
partager par un ensemble d'acteurs et
quelque part au talent de ses réflexions
là nous essayons de remonter ce qui est
bon pour le consommateur